مدينه غازي عنتاب بعد الزلزال محل موصده
ومطاعم مغلقه في مدينه كانت تنبض بالحياه
العاملون فيها تائهون بين من يحاول اجلاء
اسرته وبين من يبحث عن مكان يصلح للعيش
بعد توال الهزات
محمد واحد من هؤلاء عاش رعب ليله الزلزال
مع اسرته تنقل بين الاقامه في المساجد
وصلاه العزاء ثم استقر به المقام هنا مع
والدته واطفاله لم يفكر محمد في مشكله
اطعام اسرته فالمراكز التي اعدتها بلديه
غازي عنتاب بالتعاون مع المتطوعين وجمعيات
خيريه توزع يوميا ملايين الوجبات الساخنه
بالاضافه الى توزيع الطعام علينا يقوم
مجموعه من اهل الخير بتوزيع احتياجات
الاطفال كالحليب وغيره لكن هذا لا يمنع
وجود السلوكيات غير لائقه من البعض هنا
كالشرقه والاحتكار
المدينه والولايات العاشر المتاثره
بالزلزال كحال محمد باتوا يعتمدون على
الوجبات المجانيه
بل بانه من فئه خمس نجوم الان بامكاني
سكان المدينه غنيهم وفقيرهم تناول طعامه
وبالمجان في مظهر من مظاهر التكافل التي
ظهرت بعد الزلزال والتي خففت من معاناه
الالاف
يشرف الشيف نوح على فريق من موظف المطعم
والمتطوعين يحرص على معايير الجوده
المعتاده وكان شيئا لم يحدث
تصلهم المواد الاوليه من جمعيات خيريه ومن
البلديه فيعدون ويقدمون مئات الالاف من
الوجبات يوميا لمحتاجيها يقدم هذا المطعم
بفروعه ومطاعم اخرى في ولايه غازي عنتاب
ملايين الوجبات
نوفر الطعام والشراب نعمل على مدار اليوم
ونوفر عبر فروعنا ملايين الوجبات
للمحتاجين
تظافر الجهود الحكوميه والخاصه ازاح عن
المتضررين من الزلزال اهم البحث عن الطعام
مؤقتا لكن الى متى بظل غياب افق زمني واضح
لموعد نهايه عيش المشردين في الشوارع
خصوصا في الولايات الاكثر تاثرا بالزلزال
وهو سؤال
سكان المخيمات
ياسين الجزيره
غازي عنتاب